the Joe Rogan experience so I brought up
that makeup boy and the makeup of my
daughter's in love with she washes his
makeup one tube and now he's been
cancelled I understand he lost three
millionaire and she's she was telling me
to have an eleven-year-old sit down and
tell you about a gay makeup artist and
this is the funny part she goes well
there was a couple things okay so there
was the thing with he has a friend who
and he tells me this woman's name who
got him into the business and then she
asked him to promote her hair stuff but
he said no and he went with another hair
stuff so he totally totally betrayed her
all right it's like my 11 year olds
telling me this and then this was the
best part she goes there was also some
talk that you know he's gay and there
was boys that were not gay and he tried
to get them to be in a room with him
it's like listening to an 11 year old
tell me more by the way that also could
have been how that's how that's the tone
of the internet anyway as an 11 year old
girl at least it came from an 11 year
girl instead of like so-and-so's
cancelled like ya know you're a [ __ ]
45 don't look why why are you talking
like a little girl you're on a [ __ ]
you're on BuzzFeed you're on Fox like
it's in the point where the New York
Times is gonna be doing that like did
sit close to it now I mean I think that
Alabama owns abortion people yeah what
it is is the media right now especially
journalism they're [ __ ] starving for
hits it's just so hard to make money
it's so hard so they're drowning yeah
and so they're trying to grab whatever
branches they can yeah they gotta make a
good story with a click Beatty title
[ __ ] deceptive title who gives a [ __ ]
yeah we got a good story that story's
vetted yeah and even if it's not totally
vetted if it's a little slippery but
that you can make an amendment later you
know I'm sorry we a little bit an
apology and we have to make a retraction
yeah nobody reads those goddamn
retractions know you should have to have
a retract if you if you [ __ ] up so
hardcore that you attribute a crime to
someone or you do something like that
and make it a retraction it should be on
the front page your paper and nothing
else for a month
yeah that's it this is your newspaper no
I'm sorry we don't get to tell you the
news anymore by the way [ __ ] this up so
hard that we printed out to millions of
people you have to just put in a little
column in the corner yeah we'd like to
upon us up last month also 9/11 happen
though planes brought into the World
Trade Center and too hard to be a
journalist man well that's what I this
is what another thing I want to talk
about which is absolute meaning if you
believe like I still believe in like
institutional journalists I believe in
New York Times I believe in as well
Washington Post like so and you use the
fact that they wrote about a UFC fight
they just said he was bloody and early
McGregor he wasn't just a bad very bad
description it was very inaccurate I'm
like why would you do that you guys are
crazy that the New York Times is
allowing this yeah completely an
accurate description of something that
millions of people's yeah it's so silly
and it makes everybody question
everything else you say and you might
think it's trivial because it's just a
boxing match but it's completely
inaccurate yeah and completely
exaggerating what actually went down
well if you've had articles written
about you today [ __ ] up everything yeah
every but now having said that we can't
dismiss all like there needs to be an
absolute kind of an absolute truth and
that's what I feel like is sort of
melting in this era of anyone goes like
well they said this and that's not true
so everything else they say is [ __ ]
[ __ ] right of course which I think
the the Trump does a lot and I think
people are all too happy to believe it
because they resent institutions they
resent these smartypants [ __ ]
which I also get I get the impulse
I just don't think New York Times right
yes a smartness the old gray lady yeah
and it's like it just plays on every
stereotype like there are so many
stereotypes of work that can make you
write it off I think we're in a
transitionary period that's what I think
I think what do you think it gets
replaced by them
that's the
problem the real problem is they they
have all their pieces all the best
journalists right all the best people
are all locked into two ancient systems
one ancient system is print medium the
other ancient system is broadcast medium
the broadcast medium the ancient product
part of it is it has to go on at a
certain time Tuesdays at 8:00 p.m. and
then you have to sit there and wait for
the commercials unless you DVR it right
so that's inherently flawed and then the
print medium well they figured out a way
to get it on your laptop and your phone
now so okay they've got a little bit of
a workaround there but they have a
really hard time getting people to sign
up for digital subscriptions is the
distributions not nearly as good as it
used to be yeah it's hard it's hard to
get people to buy newspapers but at
least they've they've got their foot in
the door with clicks idols like The
Times in the post or yeah are pretty
successful online they're actually doing
much better because of President Trump
yeah because he talks so much [ __ ] about
them the people actually said I need to
see what the New York Times what is it
[Applause]